مراسلتنا السلام خضر موجوده ايضا في
اديمان لتحدثنا عن
الطريقه التي يتم استقبال فيها مثل هذه
التصريحات في وقت يعاني فيه الناس بهذه
الظروف القاسيه والمؤلمه للغايه
ليلى وضع المدينه كارثي بالفعل على جميع
المستويات مستوى الدمار الذي احدثه
الزلزال الاول ومات له زلزال الثاني وايضا
الهزات الارتداديه كبير جدا وواسع
الابنيه المنهارات في جميع انحاء هذه
المدينه في المكان الذي نحن فيه هنا نحن
منذ نحو ثلاث ساعات ليله هذا المبنى انهار
في الزلزال الاول فجر يوم الاثنين قتل تحت
انقاضه ما يقرب من 200 شخص بحسب ما
افادتنا السلطات المحليه اليوم عند قرابه
الرابعه من بعض الظهر وصلت فرق الاسعاف
الانقاذ عفوا الى سماع صوت خافت من تحت
الانقاض تبين انها سيده في العقد السادس
عالقه تحت الركام وما زالت على قيد الحياه
منذ الرابعه وفرق الانقاذ والاطفائيه
يحاولون انتشال السيده الخبر الجيد انها
حتى الان هي على قيد
المسعفين وصلوا الى السيده وقدموا لها
العنايه الاوليه الضروريه
لابقائها لمساعدتها على المقاومه حتى
يتمكن رجال
الانقاذ من انتشالها من تحت ركام هذا
المبنى ايضا هناك عناصر من فوج الاطفاء هم
الذين يتولون توسعه المكان الذي
تتواجد فيه السيده بايديهم من دون استخدام
اي الات على الاطلاق ليله نظرا لان المبنى
هش للغايه او ما تبقى الركام الذي تبقى من
المبنى هش للغايه اي حركه عنيفه قد تؤدي
الى انهيارات
وتعيد تمر السيده في المكان الذي تتواجد
فيه الجميع هنا يترقب منذ الرابعه ان يتم
انتشار هذه السيده خاصه وان هذا الحي الذي
نحن فيه ليله يشهد دمار كبير منذ ان وصلنا
هنا منذ بعد الظهر تقريبا تم انتشال من
هذا المبنى التي ترونه ومباني مجاوره اكثر
من خمس اشخاص كانوا قد فارقوا الحياه هذه
السيده هي الامل بالنسبه للموجودين هنا
جميعا وهي الامل بالنسبه
لكثيرين من سكان هذه المدينه مثل هذا
الموقع يتكرر المشهد في اكثر من مكان
الامل بان يتم العثور على مزيد من الاحياء
الرقم الاول لاعداد الضحايا في المدينه
يصل الى حوالي الف شخص هذا احصاء اولي
السلطات المحليه تقول انها لا تستطيع ان
تعلن عن اعداد المفقودين هناك الكثير من
المفقودين لا يزالون تحت الانقاض الجميع
يحاول ان يعمل بسرعه ولكن هناك معوقات
كبيره جدا ابرزها احتمال انهيارات مباني
اخرى مجاوره للمباني التي انهارت او حتى
بعيده عنها هناك المئات من الابنيه في
المدينه متضرره بشكل كبير بعضها لم يقع
هناك شروخ وصدوع فيه وبعضها الاخر
سقط جزئيا وليس كليا وهذا هو الخطر الذي
تتخوف منه فرق الانقاذ وفرق الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني الرئيس اردوغان زار اديمان
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم تحدث الى السكان وعدهم
بان يتم تلبيه الاحتياجات الاساسيه لهم
للبقاء لتمكن من اجتياز الفتره التي تلت
بشكل مباشر هذا الزلزال سيحاولون ايجاد
اماكن ايواء
ليله في هذه الاثناء هناك مستعد يتوجه
بالحامله المخصصه لنقل المصابين يتجه لا
ادري ان ربما ترونه في الكاميرا الان يذهب
يتوجه بها الى فرق الانقاذ عند نعم قد
نكون امام احتماليه انتشار قريبه جدا هذه
هي المره الاولى الذي يقترب فيها مسعف
ويحمل
لوحا يعني يستخدم لنقل المصابين